RACHEL: Today I'm very, very
excited to host our speaker,
author Sarah Drew.
And I have a little
intro for her
to talk about the
"Gaia Codex" talk,
the talk about feminine
wisdom and the evolution
of technology.
I actually know Sarah
as a personal friend
and I think she's one of
the most inspiring women who
embodies feminine values.
I think if you just watch her on
stage you'll know what I mean.
But I'm really pleased
that she's here
today to talk about her book.
So a little bit
about that and we'll
go ahead and hand
it over to her.
So basically the "Gaia Codex" is
what we're going to talk about
and this is both an
ancient found wisdom text
and a sumptuous epic novel.
"Gaia Codex" reveals
the hidden histories
of a world long forgotten,
the secret wisdom
of an ancient lineage of women.
Set in a near future
of impending societal
and environmental
collapse, the novel
is a tale of hope
and remembrance
as well as an inspired
vision of humanity's origins,
and on the potential we hold
for conscious evolution.
Very important topic.
With growing numbers of
international readers,
"Gaia Codex" is a
flourishing phenomena
that is capturing the passionate
spirit of the feminine rising
and our deepening reconnection
to our Mother Earth,
and very timely with
Earth Day coming up.
A life-long explorer of
cultural consciousness, Sarah
has traveled the world from
the high plateaus of Tibet,
to the jungles of the Amazon,
to remote villages in Buton.
She studied religious
studies at UC Berkeley
and has lectured internationally
and at the graduate level
on topics such as
technology and consciousness
and the design of mind.
Sarah's consulting and
innovation firm Metamuse
brings seasoned
expertise in the areas
of innovation media,
emergent technologies,
and evolutionary culture.
Metamuse works with
clients and companies
to help shape regenerate
vital cultures that
catalyze the optimum
potential of the human species
and honor the sanctity
of Mother Earth.
Sarah lives in Mill
Valley, so she's local,
and please welcome Sarah.
[APPLAUSE]
SARAH DREW: Thank you, Rachel.
It's wonderful to be here
with all of you today
and to be here at Google.
And may our time here together
benefit all beings, benefit
life.
I'm going to be doing a
little exploration about how
we, as a species, can create
vibrant, regenerative cultures
at this critical point
in our evolution.
Now a little bit
later we're going
to go deep into the
"Gaia Codex" and are
going to be looking at
how we, as women and men,
can reconnect with the
ancient wisdom that is
the feminine wisdom traditions.
But right now I want to
look at how we can create
conscious, wise technology.
There's an ancient
body of wisdom
and our emergent
cultural knowing
that our Mother
Earth, Terra Gaia,
is a living, breathing entity.
We are part of her
and she is part of us.
She is consciousness, the pure
vibration of consciousness.
And she is matter.
Evolving, learning,
experimenting, and breathing.
An endless stream
of knowing, we are
but one of the many forms
of life co-emergent with her
over time.
Pythons, and elephants,
Redwood trees, and lotuses,
ancient tyrannosauruses,
saber toothed tigers,
and ferns whose origin
spread back 350 million years
in their origins.
We human beings,
we homo sapiens,
have only been here
for a blip in time
in the history of Mother Gaia.
200,000 years in a 2.5, in
a 4.5 billion year history.
And if we dig deep into
our DNA's own knowing,
we find that Gaia
is ever evolving
and that we are just
part of this living
consciousness, this
evolving spirit of life
running through us.
And I'd like to pose
that technology is also
part of Gaia's blueprint.
Now in its optimum
form, technology
is consciousness manifest
and deeply resonant
with life flourishing
here on Mother Earth.
I'm going to say
this one more time.
In its optimum form, technology
is consciousness manifest,
consciousness manifest,
and deeply resonant
with life flourishing
on my Mother Earth.
Now there's a lot
of debate right
now about different
scenarios of how
we are evolving as a
species, especially
in regards to technology.
And kind of the simplistic
polarity of that right
now can be, on one hand,
there's the AI singularity.
Human beings and carbon
life would become obsolete.
This is scenario that we've seen
played out in many Hollywood
movies at this point.
One of the factors of
this is that technology
is seen as something
separate from us
and Mother Gaia, in this
sense, is seen not as a living,
breathing entity
but as a resource
to be extracted to
develop technology.
What I'd like to pose is that
technology is indeed actually
part of our self and that
we are sacred technology.
And in particular,
our Mother Earth
is one of the most
extraordinary technologies
that we can learn from.
Our Mother Gaia is a 4.5
billion years library of wisdom,
of living technology,
is here for us
to cherish and to learn from.
And we have a choice about
how we evolve as a species.
We're all part of the
participants in this game,
in this divine play.
There is a wonderful word,
a Sanskrit word, lila,
which means the divine
play that creates worlds.
What lila presupposes
is that we are actually
[? creaking ?] our creations
with consciousness,
or at least the aspiration
towards awakened consciousness
that understands the
laws of causalities.
All our actions have an effect.
And that we work within a
web of interconnected being,
and that we're here to
the best of our ability
to benefit all beings
and to benefit all life.
So from this view,
this middle way,
that we are living, breathing
technology, sacred technology
and consciousness,
and that we're
a part and intrinsic to Mother
Gaia who is also a technology
and consciousness, there's
a couple of anchor points
to look at.
One, that technology is
a tool for the evolution
of consciousness.
It's a teaching tool
and in its optimum form
can be used as a bridge
to activate qualities
that the human being
already has within oneself.
A lot of areas that
have been covered
in the esoteric
traditions, which we'll
go into too in a
minute, technology
at this point in
time in its evolution
is there as an
externalization of that.
The other, that Mother Gaia is
a 4.5 billion year old library
and blueprint of a highly
functional and sustainable
technology.
And we've only scratched the
surfaces of what is here.
And it's our imperative to
nourish her and to sustain her,
and to learn from her.
Not to burn her, not
to pollute her rivers,
not to cut down her forest or
blast out her mountaintops.
It's equivalent to destroying
the library of Alexander, maybe
even worse because it's 4.5
billion years of information
and data which can inform how
we are living on the planet.
And this goes into
a lot of the work
and teachings, which
you're probably aware of,
of Janine Benyus
with biomimicry.
Looking to the Mother
Earth to find design
for evolving technology.
And also Bucky Fuller who is
working with Planet Ship Earth.
The third thing, we
must make the transition
from extractive
technologies to technologies
where the energy sources
are regenerative so
that we don't
continue to deplete
the resources of the planet,
and that we're looking forward
to not just to seven
generations ahead,
but we're looking
forward to how do
we keep the planet
livable for homo
sapiens for the next millennia.
A doorway into standing
technology and regenerative
energy is maybe to dive
into the metaphysics
or esoteric practices.
These have often been, in a
span of many human traditions,
a bridge to understanding
this precious give
of life and our Mother Gaia.
Across our epics, cultures
and epics of time,
there's been these
practices that
allow us to go directly
in to the wisdom
of our sacred technology
of a human being.
Now probably many of you
are familiar with yoga
and probably practice it.
The first level of yoga,
when we go into a yoga class,
we'll just be working with
the physical body, right?
We're going to get in shape.
We're going to do our asanas.
Go one layer deeper, we
start to work with the energy
systems of the body, which
is, in Sanskrit, what
it is, there's a whole
network called nadis.
The nadis are a
nodal network that
are there, which is
an energy system.
You learn how to activate that.
They're there and
they're in alignment
with the chakras,
which in that system
are understood to be portholes
to activating the body's
full energy and
consciousness potentials.
Very key in that is the
balance between the male
and the female.
It's called the
pingala and the ida.
The sun and the moon.
They understand
that a whole human
being is a balance between
the male and the female.
Mindful medication
is-- I know many of you
here are practicing-- helps
clear the mind so that we
understand where
thoughts come in
and what we're receptive
to, what types of creation
we are actually bringing forth.
When the mind is still
and the mind is clear
we can start to bring forth with
choice, conscious creations.
Causality, there's
a couple of things,
you can go also into Western
alchemy which is working,
in the Western
alchemic tradition
again, is working at how to
use the technology of a human
being.
The coding or the
symbolic form of that
was the transmutation
of material
which became part of the
history of chemistry.
But its inner practices
were esoteric practices
about how we transmute
the human being so
that we have a direct connection
with consciousness itself.
And there's an equation, it
was like an energetic equation,
whether it was tantra,
whether it was yoga,
whether it's alchemy, that
the human being is a microcosm
and we are a mere replica
of the macrocosms, which
is consciousness.
And if we understand how
to align these energies
and go into that, we have the
full energy of a potential.
We aren't just
bodies of material
but we are also consciousness.
We're also light.
We're also vibration.
And this, from my
understanding, this fusion
of pure consciousness
with our material bodies
and our understanding of
working within a network of how
we can benefit all beings and
all life is really critical.
Again, across these traditions,
inter connectivity, all of life
is connected.
You'll find this through
many of these traditions.
There's causality, or
effects have action.
This could come across in
karma in the Western Buddhism
or the Golden Rule
in Christianity.
And love, that pure vibration
of the heart where we really
hold care and compassion
for other beings.
And that replicates
itself out in our actions.
And finally, what
is so essential
for this point in time is the
reclaiming of our relationship
with the feminine
part of ourselves
and our reconnection
into Mother Gaia.
So "Gaia Codex" is a novel
written as an ancient found
wisdom text.
It's about an ancient
lineage of women
called the Priestesses
of Astera who
have been holding
rejuvinecation codes
for the planet for millennium.
The story takes place a
flash moment right after now
when there's environmental
crisis, a culture
right at the brink of either
transformation or collapse.
It's also a remembrance
into the deep roots
of our collective past.
"Gaia Codex" is a
reclaiming and the recasting
of the lost history of
the sacred feminine, which
in many cultures is a lost
part of our shared human story.
So I'm going to read now from
the prologue to the book.
I'll give you a taste of
how we go into the world.
Now to the easy part.
[LAUGHTER]
SARAH DREW: "Through
the flow of ages
and the rise and
fall of cultures,
a secret codex has been
inscribed with the tales
and stories, the
rites and rituals
of priestesses
who are emanations
of the eternal goddess.
Caretakers and guardians of
our Mother Earth, Terra Gaia.
In India and China, in ancient
Sumer, in ancient Greece
and Egypt, in the Serengeti,
and in the Amazon,
and in the Celtic wilds, there
flows a timeless tradition
amongst those who've walked the
Earth who revere and remember
the circle of life.
Passed from
grandmother to mother,
daughter to sister,
aunt to niece,
held safe in the heart of
sisters who have incarnated
through the ages.
This text is not written on
pages, paper, or papyrus.
Instead it is inscribed
in holograms of light,
in the leaves of
trees, the hum of bees
and the codes of spiral DNA.
Hidden from many,
the Codex is known
to those with the eyes
to see, the ears to hear,
and the heart to feel that
which lies just beyond the veil.
It is said that the
Gaia Codex contains
jewel seeds of planetary
destiny for all beings
and life on Planet Earth.
These women, these
priestesses of Astera
have sheltered and protected the
Codex, and when necessary, kept
it hidden and ready for those
moments of extraordinary crisis
and transformation
when it will be
needed once more
for the nourishment
and regeneration of humankind."
Now the book has
been out since August
and it's been really
amazing to receive--
and it's being read
all over the world,
have readers in Malta, and
South Africa, and Finland,
and down in South American,
and over in Japan, and all over
North America.
And it's been really amazing
to get these long letters
from women saying, I know this.
There's something
that I remember.
And what they will describe is
their own childhood memories,
their own breakthrough memories.
Many of us have had this, when
we've gone into a place that's
either ecstasy or crisis.
Where the veils become
a little thinner
and we remember these essence
truths about our own soul,
about our people.
And each of the women
that are writing
are adding in their own story.
And how I understand
the Codex is working
is more as an open source code.
It's a narrative,
but it's also there
as an activator for our
essence connection with life.
I'm going to read
another passage here.
And these are from,
at the beginning
of each of the chapters, there's
these codes, or Gaia Codex
Nodes.
"There are Priestesses of
Astera whose bodies and minds
have been dedicated
as temples of memory.
Into these women's
bones, flesh, and organs,
into their very cells, are
poured historical events
and knowledge for safekeeping.
In these women,
these memory keepers,
are stored jewels of revelation,
boons for healing and creation.
Some say the true
gift of these women
is their ability to seamlessly
connect with all life itself,
to read the ancient records
in the tiniest grain of sand,
in the veins of a leaf, in
a constellation of stars,
or in the softness of
a kiss upon the lips.
These memory keepers
are both empty and full
as they carry the
wisdom through the ages.
Gaia Codex Node 44.54281."
There's an ancient
Buddhist sutra
called the Avatamsaka Sutra,
which is one of my favorite.
It's Mahayana Buddhist.
It was actually put into written
form in fourth, fifth century
BCE.
And what it is, is this
amazing holographic text
of how reality is structured.
It's 1,000 pages in written
form and it talks about,
very central to it, indra's
net, which probably many of you
know about.
And an indra's net is this
infinite inter dimensional net
where at every node
there is a pearl that
reflects all the other pearls.
And it's talked about as
a inner technology that
has been discovered by
people who, in this case,
were following the
Buddhist path and were
going on the path of
being a bodhisattva.
The book also talks
about the stages
of becoming a bodhisattva
and how we cultivate that.
And there's some beautiful
descriptions of the body,
they call it the
Buddha Body, but this
is our body when we are
in awakened consciousness.
And it will talk about
billions of worlds
being on one little strand
of hair, and you know,
each fingertips holds
the eon of the ages.
And so it's this way of where we
become multi-dimensional beings
through conscious
contemplative practice.
And I would say as women we
have a very close relationship
to our bodies and a
care of our bodies
as containers of the universe
and containers of life.
Working with women,
when I've done that,
kind of the entry
point often is first
that place of where we're
feeling the pain and the sorrow
of generations of unbalance.
And all of us as human
beings-- and for men
too-- we're both
male and female.
And balance is what we are
striving for right now,
what we're cultivating,
what were nourishing.
So it's cultivating
the activation
of the feminine rising
but it's also cultivating
the honoring of the
masculine part of our self
in relationship to the female.
One of the sacred technologies
that women have is the circle.
And the sacred circle is a
way of activating energies
and activating direct
connection into wisdom streams,
as it's understood in
the sacred feminine.
It's the activation
of the matrix,
but the original meaning of
the matrix, which means womb.
I also, it kind of makes
me laugh that hysteros is
Greek for the wandering womb.
So hysteria happens when
the womb is wandering.
So it's important to
anchor these circles.
And to anchor it together
with other women,
it becomes a place where we
can start to directly connect
with the codes of
the planet, directly
connect with the wisdom
that wants to come through,
directly connect with
the creations that
want to come through right
now and give life and form.
This technology of the sacred
circle with women gathering
is a means to activate new
life and to connect to life.
I think there's really
many women right now that
are giving voice to this rising
sacred feminine within us,
and many men that I've met
too that are supportive of it.
It's a call to continue
life, and healthy life,
here on our planet.
When I really started to
feel the tears of Gaia,
when you start to see
devastated rain forests,
when you see mountaintops in
Virginia that have been blasted
off, this is our body.
This is source to life.
And we may be cosmic
universal beings,
we may be beings of pure
mind and intelligence,
but we are citizens.
We are part of the Mother
Earth and if we destroy her
in the way that we're
going right now,
it will not be here
for our children.
And we have a responsibility
as women and as men
to cultivate life.
Part of it is feeling
it, is feeling
the pain of what we, as
a culture, have done.
And it's not easy.
We do a lot of things to
intoxicate ourself-- all of us
have, I have-- to not feel.
But we need to feel.
And from that we can create
a new way of doing things.
That was unexpected.
[LAUGHTER]
SARAH DREW: Where
to go from there?
I want to talk a bit about
just the gathering of women,
again from the book.
It's called "The
Temples of Astera."
These women are called
the Priestesses of Astera.
"Most have forgotten that
the Temples of Astera exist.
This is by design.
Our temples have been
carefully protected,
for in many cultures
and political climates
the revelation of our
temples' existence
has meant a certain death.
Conquerors built their
temples on our sacred grounds,
but even stone edifices
at some point fall.
The wheel is always turning.
Our temples are found
in forest groves,
in the reflection of
a clear glacial lake
or on the mountaintop.
You may find such a
temple inside a simple hut
or at the back of an
unassuming merchant shop.
It is known that our physical
bodies are one of our most
profound and sacred temples.
The Temples of Astera
have been designed
to look common to the common
eye but for those with the eyes
to see, the Temples of Astera
are radiant with light.
They're the repositories of
what has been and what may be,
once again, on our mother.
The Temples of Astera
take inspiration
from the natural harmonics
of nature herself,
from the subatomic
to the cosmic,
the walls of our temples
are resonating, fluctuating
between light and matter, hence
their fluidity and ability
to transform in the
eye of the beholder,
Our temples are
portals where you
can enter deeper
dimensions, both in the past
and in the future,
palimpsest, where
multiple dimensions co-exist.
Stand in the center of
one and you're anchored
inside the wheel of life.
All the elements,
earth, water, and fire,
wind are all there
in equal proportion."
So I think the
simplest way to close
is that we are here
as defenders of Gaia.
We're the voice of Mother Gaia,
whether we are male or female.
We're vessels into
which the future becomes
manifest in every one of us.
It's time for us to wake
up from the days, the mire
of repetitive
action, to go deeper
into our central consciousness
and to understand
when a meme or a seed
is planted inside of us
and to understand
and give caution
to what we're propagating
for the future.
For those of you here, we're
essential to shaping reality
through technology.
Consider the impact
of what we're creating
on generations to come.
Let's create wise, conscious
technologies which nourish life
and consider the well
being of all being.
And for the women
in the audience,
it's important for
us in particular
to return to our ancient ways,
the tried and true technologies
of our lineage.
But to do it, for at this moment
now, at this critical choice
point, it's time
for us to gather
in circles large and
small and to open
the portals for what has been
long hidden and forgotten.
For we are defenders
of Mother Gaia
and we are defenders of life.
And we're here to create a
vibrant life-affirming future
for our children and
our children's children
for generations to come.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
RACHEL: So I know
that from the book
you have some really
great imagery, just
wonderful beautiful images.
So can you talk a little bit
about that and the inspiration
for those?
Where did those come from?
And they're just beautiful.
SARAH DREW: Thank you.
RACHEL: Yeah.
SARAH DREW: Yeah,
such a great question.
When I'm creating--
and it's interesting,
I'm working with a lot
of clients right now
who are writing and
women and men who
are bringing in a lot of these
new flows of information.
And I found that I actually
receive the information first
as a visual.
What I mean by that is
that there will be--
and this is like going
into the creative process.
When I went to write
the book there was this,
a scene would come in and it
would be like watching a movie.
And for me, it was so
visceral and so sensorial.
And I was just the transcriber
writing, you know, OK, wow.
OK, this is happening.
This is happening
to the character.
And even though a
lot of my background
had trained my mind in
the intellectual process
and had study
religions and I've been
a curator on different projects
working with global wisdom.
When it came to that
process, it was just
going into these living worlds.
And it's a way of traveling,
both in the writing process,
in the past and the future.
So those are, images
are anchors and I
see it as like a symbolic
language actually.
And it was really
essential, I thought,
in the publication
of the book to have
the images as part of
the story, like one
the ancient illuminated
manuscripts.
AUDIENCE: One of
the calls to action
that you had for
women here and just
men that may channel
their inner feminine
was to gather in circles.
And I wonder if you
could share more, like,
what you mean by that.
Is that more of
a symbolic thing?
Or I'm thinking in my brain
like new moon gatherings
or something.
SARAH DREW: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Where we gather
around the fire and like,
share stories.
I don't know.
I'm curious if you
have any suggestions.
SARAH DREW: It's
a great question.
And I think gathering
in circle is something
that's so natural once we go
into it, especially for women,
you know?
And I'm seeing it as a
grounds roots call to action,
but I'm also seeing
it as medicine.
We're doing it to come
together because there's
a lot of healing
and transmutation
that happens first, and
that's really essential.
And a lot of the energies that
we're working with right now,
none of us can do it alone.
We need to do it together.
And it really is
this place where
our personal life, our personal
joys, our personal pains,
interact with the
larger ethos of what's
happening on the planet.
With the "Gaia
Codex" there's been
women that have been
gathering around
the book, around the planet,
and it's really wonderful.
And we're going to be,
coming in the end of May,
probably mid May, we're
going to be having
just free online gatherings so
that those that are gathering--
and just some basic blueprints.
I'm really big on people
being able to access
their own knowing.
Because I think
once, what I've found
when the circle's
set up right, you
can start to access
these wisdoms
and you have these
amazing things of stuff
that maybe we
haven't been taught
that starts to flow through us.
So but anyway,
we'll be having that
and I'll give my
information at the end here.
And it would be wonderful to
see you here, all of you, there.
And men too.
And get your--
[GIGGLING]
RACHEL: Yeah.
I'm getting that it's
like a community.
So it's almost like
embracing that feminine value
and trait of community and
associating with others, men
or women, about this issue
and how we can help--
SARAH DREW: Yeah, I love--
RACHEL: Save the planet.
SARAH DREW: Yeah, thank you.
It's almost kind of going into
the root word of that, right?
The communion, the
commune, the community.
Yeah.
There's just that empathy
of the heart, right?
AUDIENCE: While
you were talking,
especially kind of when you
became overcome with emotion--
thank you for sharing that--
I was curious generally
to hear your thought process
and why-- it sounds like it's
a fiction book more or less.
Kind of how you decided to
be fiction or nonfiction
because these are also very
serious factual issues also.
SARAH DREW: I'm getting
shivers as you're saying it.
[LAUGHTER]
SARAH DREW: Thanks
for tuning in.
It was actually, when I
started to write the book
and I got that I needed
to write the book,
I actually took
three years and was
very fortunate to
receive a bequest
from Shawn Hailey, who was an
early Silicon Valley inventor.
You can go over in Silicon
Genesis over at Stanford,
did a lot of work with biochip.
She's passed.
And I say she because
she became a transgender
at the end of her life.
And it could've been fiction or
it could have been nonfiction.
And I felt that fiction,
at this point in time,
allows us to have
more brain elasticity,
to just stretch your
imaginations a bit more on what
could be without
having to go into--
and I do it too-- going into
our critical mind of like, well,
no, this isn't how
it is right now,
or going into it logic so much.
So it was a very specific
choice with that.
Yeah, just to give
us more-- and I
wanted to give a real
visceral, sensorial experience,
where sometimes
with facts, I mean,
facts done well are going
to be visceral and sensorial
but I wanted to have
more of this real,
something you can taste,
and eat, and smell.
Yeah.
It's a great question.
AUDIENCE: I'm just
about to finish
this year and a half
immersion called
Inner Yoga, this whole thing.
And I just started
a new job here
and I'm kind of crossing
these two worlds.
So I'm glad you're here today.
[LAUGHTER]
SARAH DREW: I'm glad
you're here too.
AUDIENCE: And I was
just wondering more
about your personal background
of your spiritual influences
or rituals that led to this.
And if there's
any, I don't know,
just certain practices that
you do regularly, or rituals,
or people you follow,
anything else you recommend.
SARAH DREW: Mm.
Thank you.
I'll make it brief.
My journey's been a long one.
You know, when I was
19, 20, I started out
in a completely different
field and then got--
which I know some
Googlers did-- that I
need to take three years off
and travel around the world.
[LAUGHTER]
SARAH DREW: And I ended up
going to Tibet and India
and down in the Amazon.
And then came back and
went to UC Berkeley
and studied religious studies.
I was in journalism
to begin with.
I was going to become a
television anchor or something.
[LAUGHTER]
SARAH DREW: And then
from religious studies
I went into technology and
had a high-tech startup
in the '90s that was
working with earlier
forms of virtual reality.
So my practice became
the crack open.
It wasn't pretty.
It was messy, you know?
It was like me going and
just the top of the head
being ripped open and all of
a sudden, everything that I
thought was true wasn't true.
And I needed to--
my solution to that
was to travel to Tibet in 1984
and sit with Buddhist monks.
And a lot of my
practice right now
is in the Tantric
Buddhist yoga tradition.
My main teachers are in Buton.
And I meditate every day,
I work with the goddesses.
Sally Kempton, I don't know
if you know of her work,
she's been one of my
mentors for many years.
So the embodiment I think for
women, the Hindu and Buddhist
Tantric tradition for
embodying the goddess,
I find really useful.
Because there are these
whole templates and they're
almost like kind of
synesthetic multimedia
templates of how we can have
all the information embodied
in there.
And it's a really interesting
technology actually,
I think, because you have like
a, as you know, a mandala.
But a mandala also has
a linked connection
into a mantra,
which is the sound.
Which also has a
linked connection
into the image of the goddess
if that's easier for you
to just kind of,
oh, I will be her.
We'll resonate together, right?
And so it's a fairly, I
found, sophisticated system
of embodiment and
they cultivating
this deep karmic compassion.
So I really look forward to
hearing more about your journey
because it just feels like
it's something really big
and whatever you're-- I mean,
not to put you on the spot
in the room in front of--
AUDIENCE: Sure.
We can talk after.
SARAH DREW: But it feels, I can
feel that after these couple
years, there's something
quite extraordinary you're
bringing through.
So thank you.
AUDIENCE: I had
one more question.
So when you were
getting the visuals
and trying to write
this, was it all at once?
Like it took three
years to write
but did you just get
an entire story line
and know what you were
exactly going to write or was
it piece by piece and
unfolded over years?
What happened?
SARAH DREW: Right.
The way that I received
the information--
and it's interesting that
in this Illuminated Creation
Writing Program that
we're doing right now,
a lot of the, almost
all the students
that signed up for the program,
are receiving the information
in similar ways, which is
like a blueprint at first.
I received it as kind of
like a mandalic blueprint.
And I actually took
a piece of paper,
drew down certain
images, put down
certain key words of what
the key memes, if you will,
on the book.
Key information were there.
And then I didn't
pressure myself
to say OK, let's start
at the beginning.
I just let whatever
scene would come up.
And there was these
key anchor scenes.
One of them for the
"Gaia Codex" was,
there's this extraordinary
gathering of women
at the Chateau Lumiere
and all of the sudden,
I found myself in the
midst of this room
with women from all
different cultures and places
who were gathering at this
particular time on the planet
to bring about rejuvenation.
And it was so sensorial.
I mean, I was in tears.
And my job as a writer at
that point was just to--
[LAUGHTER]
SARAH DREW: I was the
scribe really, you know.
So a lot of the key scenes would
come like that, and pretty much
in their complete form.
And then narrative, arc,
and structure, you know,
it basically took a heroine's
journey was the narrative
structure.
And then of course
editing is a whole other,
I won't say editing
is a bitch but--
[LAUGHTER]
SARAH DREW: It's a
whole other process.
I was very lucky to have some
wonderful people to work with.
Anyway, wonderful to
be here and thanks
for your great questions.
If you're interested
in diving in deeper,
you can go to www.gaiacodex.com.
For those of you here today,
the book is available over here.
It's also available on Amazon
as well as the website.
I am offering a nine week
one-on-one mentoring program,
The Illuminated Creation,
The Art of Visionary Writing,
where we dive in deep and
both look at structural stuff.
And it's really
geared towards, if you
feel that you're
bringing in a new code
or creation for this next
phase of our human existence,
then this is a good one.
And women and men are invited.
And finally for those who
have projects and start
ups who are working with
emergent evolutionary culture,
I consult with
different companies
and bring together wisdom
circles of both men and women
on how we can make
this transition
into evolutionary culture.
And that's at metamusemedia.net,
www.metamusemedia.net.
So glad to be here
with all of you.
RACHEL: Great.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]